The mistake of doing yesterday,
I watch ace Ventura pet detective with
my eight year old and my 10 year old
seen that in since they
came out with a good still,
I didn't realize how Trans
phobic that fucking movie is.
Boiler alert.
The whole premise is that
there was a venture vegetated,
I gotta split alert myself cause I
forgot the whole premise was wet.
This guy steals a dolphin
and when he steals a dolphin,
ace Ventura fines,
cause he's a pet detective,
finds a tiny ruby that's at the bottom
of this dolphin tank that is missing from
a Miami dolphins ring.
And he finds out through this exhaustive
search that the one guy who he couldn't
account for his ring was a kicker
who fucked up the world series or the
Superbowl rather. Yeah. So this, this guy,
this guy that they've found out is Sean
Young in the movie who's gorgeous and
then in the movie,
take that down please.
So in the movie at the end of it,
the reveal is that Sean Young is really
this football player who wants to get
back a Dan Marino because Dan Murray,
he's goes psycho because the world
hates him because he blew the kick.
So He's a guy,
pretended to be a woman in Ace Ventura
made out with them and just like everyone,
all the cops are throwing up. Everyone's
throwing up. You can't own or no,
it's off the charts at the end he
pulls her top off and shows and she has
breasts. He was like trying to show
that she did well yeah, breasts.
And she did and he's like, well
anybody can get those in an afternoon,
but what about this?
And he pulls her pants down and then he
goes by and then everybody sees her and
she's got her legs together
so you can't see your penis.
And then from behind you see her junk
is pressed up against their butt cheeks
cause she's tucked her
penis and her vagina.
So the cops all start throwing
up and then cops start cleaning.
Cops had made out with her and
start cleaning their mouth off.
They start chewing giant wad
there. That's her, the scene.
So watch all the cops see that. And he
points to the fact that Sean, you look,
they all start throwing up.
Look, everyone's throwing up.
This is Dan Marino's throwing
up. They also see, oh,
he's getting his mouth because
he made out with her tone.
Loke the dolphins freaking out.
Everyone's freaking out.
It is so insanely trends.
Okay.
So what the left would say is the reason
that they're right is that a movie like
this won't get made anymore. And
isn't that a good thing? Maybe.
But should they pull it should go, should
it be illegal to have that on iTunes?
Of course.
Maybe someone on the world cleft might
disagree with you right now. Yeah,
they might.
You Trans phobic for defending this
horrible cisgendered heteronormative shit
movie.
That's horrible. And what's crazy,
and I guess this is a great thing.
I mean the re moralization project
is working because when I saw that,
I'm sure is, I don't know what year
did that come out to? 95 four. Okay.
So when I saw that as a 12
I don't know.
I was born in 84 I can't do math.
I want to say [inaudible] 93 I want to
say it was before I came to Hollywood.
When I saw that movie I was 10
transphobia was not a thing. No, no.
It is a thing. That's good. That's good.
When things are changing so rapidly,
but the question is where are the lines
being drawn and is the Overton window
being shrunk too small?
How do you feel about them pulling the
dukes of Hazzard off the air for the flag?
I don't know about that. You didn't know
about that? No, they pulled the deuce.
Do you understand? Do you understand how
many of these there are a day? Yes, so no,
I don't know that one.
What's that one? This one.
They've yanked the dukes of Hazzard
off television forever because the
confederate flag was on the roof of
the generally did not follow that.
I didn't know that. You cannot
watch the dukes of Hazzard anymore.
You cannot watch it.
It's not on television anymore.
It used to be on TV land all the
time. Can you get it on? No. Fuck no,
no chance. They're not going to
show that God damn awful flag.
We have a poster in the bathroom over
there of a Leonard Skinner from like 1970
[inaudible] and they have a giant
Janis Joplin I thought in the bathroom.
Other bathroom. Good jazz shopping.
Oh, that's the other bathroom. Yeah,
there's different boundaries. I like
that one. Yeah, that's great one.
That's her mugshot. I love it.
Yeah, that's right. Um, but the,
the Leonard Skinner one, they have
a giant confederate flag on stage.
Huge,
enormous in the background that was there,
like southern pride,
this idea of southern pride.
It was okay to have that flag.
I'm basically for trying to,
when it comes to the realm of art
and movies and books, leave it alone.
Try to leave it alone as much as possible.
It's generally a very good strategy.
I agree. Don't want to be in the
book banning movie banning TV,
banning business or editing.
They, they tried to mobile.
I think they did successfully, at
least in some venues. Edit. Uh,
Tom Sawyer and Huck Finn because the n
word was used prolifically, you know,
I mean the guy's name was nigger Jim.
That was the name in, in, in the book.
Cause that's how people talk back then.
And I think we need to keep that stuff
as a time capsule to show how racism was.
So normative. Yes. Yes.
It's important to, to,
to show the progress like
a Centura up like you,
she like for Trans people, keep
him for history, for Trans People.
And it's amazing that no
one's ever brought this up.
I mean I feel like this is something
that's never been discussing on from you.
Joe Rogan, the time I got shit
to do. I got, I got jokes right,
but fuck, this is, you've got an
Israel trip that I'm planning, Barry,
what are you doing to be married?
I'm not dragging you want to take you on
an amazing trip and then we're going to
go to the West Bank and you're going to
see all this stuff and you're going to
come away with loving certain parts of
it and not liking certain parts of it.
And you're going to realize it's a country
just like any other country.
Right.
But it is a democracy and it's trying
to do its best in a really rough
neighborhood and we'll go like, I want
you to see what the occupation looks like.
Like I think that's something
that's really important to see,
to get a full picture of it.
I think you're probably right.
I think it is an important
thing for people to see. Um,
I think there's a lot of parts of the
world that I need to see to really get a
grasp. Where do you want to go?
Where you're going next in the world?
You travel a lot. Yes. Um, I don't know.
I mean I'm,
my family and I,
we do a European vacation trip at that
doesn't really count. We just loud.
It's just fun. Um, went to Thailand last
year. That was fascinating. Oh, cool.
Thailand was fascinating because,
and that was kind of a vacation trip too.
But that's such a unique culture
because Thailand is run by the king.
Like if he even criticized the
king, you're, you're fucked.
Like you're in real trouble. And
his pictures everywhere, everywhere.
There's pictures of him and the throne,
like wearing like super nice
clothes and looking good. Um,
but the people are so kind.
They're so friendly and they're always
smiling and they have, you know,
there's a lot of people that you'll
run into that have very little,
but yet they don't seem to be having a
problem with that. They wear flip flops.
You're on the highway.
There's three people on a motorcycle
is a baby in a basket and I'm not
bullshitting.
No helmet.
And a friend that just went
to Thailand and she was like,
but the people are so nice. They're so
nice. They're so kind. It's so anew.
And you know, me and my family, we had,
we always, whenever we go somewhere,
we always have these real
long conversations. Um,
about like what was interesting about it
for you? Like what, what did you think?
Like I tried two kids, eight and 10, the
young ones. And I have a 22 year old too.
Okay. Um, all girls Holla. I'm
from four girls. Woo. Yeah,
it's in the genes. But
the um, the, the, the,
what's fascinating to me
about it is first of all,
I love exposing these little people
to different parts of the world.
So they get to see like what this is like,
you know,
like here we are like show him on the
map. This is American. We're over here.
We're way the fuck to
15 hours to get here.
The plane that goes 500 plus
miles an hour. It's crazy.
And just to realize like human
beings are the same but different.
We're the same everywhere,
but there's a different way we
choose to interact with each other.
And one of the things that happens is
we fall into their way when we go there.
Like if we go to Italy,
we say [inaudible], you
know, we started, I try to,
you try to start in learning, we'll just
start trying to learn some of the words,
you know, that, you know, these people
use in their culture and then, oh,
I forgot how you say it. Cup soon. Crop.
I think that's how you said it's like
thing like hello, good morning. Yeah. And,
but they all say that and everyone
makes a lotus flower with their hands.
It's so common.
Everywhere you go,
people greet you and they do this
and it's such a warm, friendly,
peaceful way of greeting each other.
And so one of the things that we
talked about it, I was like, you know,
that's how everybody is like way more
friendly and like greeting and this thing
about clasping your hands together and
they all agree to do it and everyone sort
of,
it's like this unique pattern that people
can fall into and people fall into all
sorts of patterns.
They fall into like really aggressive
patterns of honking at people on the road
and driving real fast. And then they
fall into these peaceful patterns.
And some of it's dictated by culture,
some of it's dictated by climate,
some of is dictated by the
economic situation in the
world they're in. But it's,
it's such a weird trip to go to different
places and see like, okay, yeah,
if I lived over here,
this is how I rock it.
I'd be wearing flip flops
and shorts and you know,
I'd get around this way and this is
the kind of food that I would eat.
And real spicy because you know,
you kind of have,
have those spices actually protect
against bacteria because they're there.
They're actually antibacterial.
Was the food grade fucking amazing.
We took some courses, we took classes,
we learned how to cook over there. Yeah.
It was amazing. It was amazing. But
my kid got lit up by bugs. Whew.
There's a thing there called tsetse flies.
I think that's what they're called.
I forget what they're called,
but my youngest had a horrible allergic
reaction to some of the bugs over there.
You get and you, you know, you think like,
okay, like, uh, what about, uh, you know,
there's,
there's fucking diseases that kill people.
Malaria's killed malaria has killed
more people than anything ever.
Like more people have died from malaria
than anything. Oh, I know. Yeah. Well,
that's why gates made
its, yeah, totally. Yeah.
And so you go over there like we were
going to go to Africa is one of the things
that we're going to go to,
but I'm not giving my fucking eight
year old malaria shots. Just know,
just like it's really bad dreams.
I've had some friends that Dave Foley,
who was like the sweetest
guy on the planet earth.
He was from kids in the hall
who was on news radio with me.
Dave Foley was on malaria medication
because he was going to visit his kids in
Egypt. So we had to take this
stuff and he was drinking,
you're not supposed to drink on
it. And uh, he, he was going crazy.
He doesn't even remember anything,
just going crazy,
taking reporters a microphone or as a
tape recorder away and put it in a drink.
It was like losing his marbles.
Like I had to protect him yelling at a
guy and like Crowl I'm like calm down.
Meanwhile the sweetest, kindest,
nicest guy you would ever meet.
And meanwhile he was like, like super
aggro was crazy. It didn't make any sense.
And it's the medication.